We may never know what's
nudging Oort Cloud
objects out of orbit.
But it's not the only
mystery out there.
We still don't know
where the solar system
ends.
Finding the edge of the
solar system helps us
with the bigger problem
of understanding the
solar system as a whole.
How do you know when you
have the whole solar
system until you found
the edge?
Maybe the biggest mystery
of all is that our sun
has too much stuff.
It's wandering the
cosmos with more than its
fair share. It's
possible our sun is a
thief that robbed its
sisters and brothers in a
cosmic womb.
But that extra stuff
could be our ticket out
when the sun turns up
the heat on us.